foreign
[Music]
thank you
at least in in Northwest Syria it's a
very very horrific situation right now
Syria has very weak Healthcare System we
have a crisis in addition to very bad
weather conditions and collapsed
buildings and unfortunately damaged
hospitals
[Music]
foreign
buildings we can say that the earthquake
code or safety codes with regards to the
buildings and constructions is
unfortunately not followed in some of
them or some of these collapsed
buildings were built prior to this
regulation this regulation has been in
place following the 1999 elections
[Music]
we need to do the seismic risk and
Hazard analysis before this earthquake
comes that means we had to check the
engineering structure of the soil and
the engineering structure of the existed
buildings and then we needed to modify
our buildings or our cities around these
areas but unfortunately we didn't do
that this region is not prepared
foreign